oh my god
oh my god is right cardi b showed off
her pregnant belly on instagram and her
baby on the way is already kicking
oh my god the cute moment comes days
after the rapper shocked fans at the bt
awards by announcing that she and offset
are expecting
and if her live tv reveal seems familiar
it is i was here before all of this
guess who acted now now you got an
audience if you remember cardi announced
she was pregnant with culture while
performing on saturday night live in
2018.
listen to this messed up in the back you
want a random shake
up in your bed she don't even know your
middle name
but back to baby number two i love
everything about motherhood
hardy shared these beautiful maternity
photos of her growing family
and let's take a moment to gush over how
cute culture will be
as a big sister i don't know i just get
too emotional and come to my kids
in this photo the proud mom predicted
how her two-year-old will handle being
the big sister
pointing out that they will have the
same age difference as cardi
and her younger sister hennessy she
wrote i just know these two will love
each other
so much and argue so much since they're
three years apart
just like me and henny but one thing for
sure is they'll have each other's back
like no one else ever will
it's gonna mean everything next to this
pic of hubby offset cradling her baby
bump
cardi wrote we listened to each other
communicated
prayed and then god blessed us and our
family with another little blessing
our home feels so blissful and very busy
but we are ready and so happy
thank you so much everyone for the
congrats and well wishes
in 2019 cardi told et she was already
looking to give culture some siblings
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's
it's like a feeling that it's
indescribable
it's like like
love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying there's like a
automatic smile
so it's everything everything so if one
brings you this
much joy would you double the joy
i want to have more kids you do yeah
more kids that sounds like many i mean
you know how whatever my body could take
i feel like the more my baby grows i see
like the different
levels and there's just gonna be
different levels all the time from one
year old
to going around chasing them making sure
they don't put things in their mouth
to you know five-year-old when they
start going to school
learning things interacting with other
kids there's always gonna be different
levels
yeah yeah yeah of course all right well
we're waiting on the next few
[Music]